hey what's up guys My Name Is AO welcome
to episode one of uh an Untitled Series
so I'm I'm chilling here I made a server
like you guys wanted me to Ser full
right now so uh yeah I'm I'm
recording so
uh everyone everyone
jump yeah all right um so here we are oh
these people are just going to start
killing each other I better turn god
mode on otherwise I could get
assassinated pretty damn
easily all right God mode is on uh let
me just uh Fly Above everyone
else
um
and TP
except oh people are just going to start
dying
whoa breaking my glass all right
um actually can I I'm interested
fly oh it's disabled now whoops all
right so this is going to be the first
episode of um a new Minecraft series so
this one's going to involve all you guys
as you can see there's uh well the
server's full at the moment I um yeah
server is full um at the moment I uh I I
wanted to um basically keep uh let me
just accept all these things I'm just
going to teleport everyone on the server
to me right now actually um T oh what is
it TP all the Cho there we go
love doing that um all right so this is
the server URL is um or the address
rather is
minecraft. the ch.com and um basically
this is a PVP server okay it is a PVP
server so what that means is you can see
these guys are demonstrating just how
much of a PVP server It Is by killing
each other um but basically uh yeah this
is a PVP server so if someone steals
your stuff if someone um kills you you
know that's just how it's going to roll
now I do want to bring in like a um I do
want to bring in like a point system and
get that rolling and uh actually have
like a ranking or something um there's a
few mods on it right now for example
like World guard so that no one destroys
my little castle I actually didn't build
this Castle okay um you guys did because
I just started like building the um I
started building the um just like the
the basis and um and what happened was
you guys um you guys and and I was like
it's it's a castle by the way and like
three of you found me I don't know how
you found me cuz I'm um well I mean if
if you check a look at the coordinates
it's I'll just share it with you guys
cuz you can't destroy this anyway- 345x
and 74 z um and you guys just finished
this for me so
yeah
um so that that's how it's rolling right
now um so what's going to happen is I
don't know you guys can um you guys can
join up and uh and yeah I mean we're
going to roll this uh this series all
along so a few of you guys might have
some uh some lag and stuff issues I am
running this out of my desktop in my um
at my house and again I mentioned that
my upload speed is only 2.4 so um it's
not going to be the best but um oh I
just teleported somewhere else with this
guy no one knows where I am
now
um I'm behind him I don't think he knows
I'm behind
him he he going to turn around
I think you realized maybe I should shot
yeah you guys have built this like this
is ridiculous um I don't want this to be
a bit of a collaborative building
project as well so um I'm not going to
just tell you guys
um not to you know if you guys build
something big and you don't want it
destroyed you can just tweet me or
something yay I think you saw me now um
you there's Noone else here that's cool
you can just uh let's just teleport
everyone over here actually TP all the
Cho
all right so now everyone's here wow
it's just all of them like in a in a
bunch um if you guys build something
really cool like this for example and
this is like ridiculous by the way like
look at it it just goes on
forever um if you guys build something
ridiculous like this or something that
you just don't want to uh don't want to
get destroyed then just let me know and
I'll protect it I'll make sure that no
one can destroy it but um this is a PVP
server so feel free to kill each other
I'm probably not going to cuz I'm way
too powerful um get myself like
Enchanted stuff to the uh to to the
maximum but um but yeah that's going to
be the deal
so don't exactly know what we're going
to going to be doing on the
server but um it it'll be fun it'll be
fun so uh
yeah um all right first thing I'm going
to do actually is continue building my
castle so I'm just going to go home um
Ser commands that you have by the way
are home so what you can do is you can
go set home and that will
actually like it'll it'll set home so if
I do set home for example it's going to
set home to this particular location and
then I can just type slome and it'll
actually teleport me there as you can
see um the other thing
is uh mobs are on obviously you guys can
see that oh crap I hit oh
whoops I I killed someone he's going to
hate me now
um um I'll just teleport you all
here I love doing that cuz everyone's
just like on top of each other and if I
just go like and then kill someone but
um all righty so this where everyone is
right now
um
okay so I need to I need to finish
building my damn Castle someone's stuff
is is right here the hell is going on I
really want to build um some kind of
like entrance into my castle so I don't
know how exactly I'm going to do that
but um you know what I'm actually
actually got a really good idea
um I'm just going to start I'm just
going to build like a little uh
workbench for myself and I'm going to
let's see I don't need that
crap oh there's so many um bad people
here so the skeleton
um yeah so there are mobs there are
there's everything is like enabled this
is like just is just survival Minecraft
but with like a lot of people at the
moment again I've only got room for 20
people but
um but I don't know if if anyone has
like some kind of um Minecraft uh like
service or like a host thing that they
can recommend um then let me know um I
mean it has to be good it has to
probably go up to 100 people if I'm
actually going to pay for this thing
then I want I want you know something
good obviously so like 100 people um on
a server at one time I want it to be
like really like no no lag obviously and
I want to be able to run commands from
the command line as well as um obviously
you know read all the logs and
uh yeah I'm
here and uh and do all that do all that
good stuff
so um so yeah and as well as you know
install any mod that I want to install I
want to be able to do that as well um so
so yeah that's that's sort of how I want
how I want stuff to roll um and
obviously a lot of people are
complaining about lag cuz again I am
running this from my um how do you build
ladders that's what I want to know I
think it's just a bunch of sticks right
and it's like this or
something
um yeah it is all
right so let's build let's build
ourselves um
a
ladder bunch of sticks there we go okay
so no
room okay 21 ladder that should be
enough right okay
and I don't know I guess I'll just
uh
cuz that's kind of cool right cuz if
you're like fighting someone here and
and you you know you guys might have
might have Enchanted something like uh
like punch or knockback um then you guys
can actually just push each other off
here um that's that that'll be really
cool
um so yeah I mean I do really want this
to be uh like a like a PVP server I just
want this to be like normal Minecraft I
don't want it to be anything fancy I'm
not going to like have like a currency
or like you can buy and sell Things N
none of that crap um all it's going to
be is just a um I don't even know this
existed actually what the hell is this
oh it's my um my thing it's like a
secret entrance into my house probably
get rid of that
oh
um
okay what is happening where is all
everyone's around the server so feel
free you can build anywhere absolutely
anywhere um you guys can work on project
together if you like I don't there are
basically no rules in this in this game
obviously obviously you can't cheat
though um like you can't use X-ray and
stuff like that and um but yeah I mean I
mean everything's uh everything's
rocking good so um you know feel free to
jump on the server I I will make this a
series if you guys have any suggestions
onto what we should do in this series
and if you also have a suggestion of the
name of this series please let me know
cuz I I just I don't actually yeah I
mean I I can't think of I don't know Cho
craft I think that's kind of cool so
like chern I don't want to call it
churncraft
not a big fan of that but Cho craft
sounds good so um and if I could do that
that'd be great I'm going to turn god
mode off just cuz um I don't want to
cheat here did that turn god mode off
for me didn't say
disabled oh it did hang on so if I just
jump off here am I going to lose health
I don't want to kill
myself but
um
no no enabled now what no disable yeah
there we
go but I still don't lose Health huh
maybe still got fly mode
on okay I can't fly
now all
right yeah that's what I'm talking about
all right so you still need to get food
and eat like it was normal Minecraft and
um yeah so it's a just a name and um
you guys can uh can have a good time and
I might get some of you guys into a
Skype call the problem with that is that
if I'm hosting the Skype call which I am
um This Server will start lagging a lot
cuz I remember I used to do live streams
in Minecraft and I got like 10 of you
guys into a Skype call and the the
stream just like crashed the stream was
just lagging like it just displayed one
frame like every minute it just it just
um it just it just sucked so I don't
know I mean that'd be awesome that's why
I like you guys to hang out in the Steam
Chat as well because um I don't know we
can we can work something out there as
well as in the normal chat but yeah I
mean only 20 people at the moment um
that's kind of uh it's kind of a problem
cuz
um but yeah so uh I hope you enjoyed
this first episode of Minecraft this was
just like a or whatever ch ch craft I
don't know I might call it chra for now
um this first episode of uh CH craft and
um if you did please hit the like button
and give the video a favorite and this
was sort of like a like an explanation
video so obviously there's not much um
there's not much stuff going on but um
oh Ser full um but yeah so don't if the
server's full just keep trying I mean
people people leave and join all the
time so it's not like um it's not like
it's going to be full for a few hours
you'll be fine so um anyway yeah I hope
you uh hope you like the video and um
there'll be another episode of game
programming out every day don't worry
I'm not abandoning that for the time
being I do have exams in like a few
weeks so I might have to stop for then
but um yeah yeah and new episodes of
this will come out basically whenever
I've got time so it's going to be the
end of the story I love this um I'm
using the um what's that the uh oh it's
an Ender it's an Ender guy the um I'm
actually using the Sai skin op gam style
um but I'm also using the uh what am I
the texture pack that I'm using is um
Docker craft I think it's like the light
version or something so um
can you enable us to use SL kill please
no that's that's no I'm not doing that
um but yeah anyway I'm here chilling
with Falcon Falcon fan 109 and um I'll
see you guys see you guys in the next
episode of Minecraft so um yeah later
guys